so let's review the situation that has
been emerging in greece and then dig a
little bit deeper as to their options so
as we saw in the last video greece was
spending
it was spending a lot more than it was
bringing in in tax revenues
then its revenue so it was running it
was running these deficits and year
after year these deficits were piling up
and the national debt and the national
debt was increasing and to make matters
worse greece actually tried to cover
this up for many years with some
accounting shenanigans because there
were some europe there were some
european central bank rules about how
much debt you could take on and so it
was trying to not trigger those rules
while still being able to take more take
on more debt so that it could fund so
that it could fund this spending right
over here but then in the last few years
it became clear the shenanigans were
cleared up and when they were cleared up
one it made people realize wow that was
kind of shady what they did but on top
of that they had a much larger
government public debt burden than
people thought
larger
than
than thought
and the combination of the two the
combination that this country was
actively trying to kind of not make its
obligations apparent to the to the to be
transparent to the markets and on top of
that that this debt burden was so huge
and made people wary of whether the
company would actually over the country
would actually be able to fulfill its
obligations so trust
trust investor trust when i talk about
investors i'm talking about the people
who would invest in greek bonds so
essentially the lenders to greece their
trust went down and they expected higher
interest
so they expected higher interest
from from the greek government and that
made things worse now not only did they
have to full keep spending on all of
their entitlements but now the costs of
funding that existing debt that they
already had and nothing new debt that
they had to do to keep spending at that
rate the cost of that debt itself went
up and that only kind of added fuel to
this ever this ballooning debt problem
now in the last video we explored a
couple of options in particular we said
what about austerity what about the
situation where you just really mainly
you could try to increase your revenues
or slash spending but people really try
to focus on the spending side what if we
really just tried to slash the spending
in a very severe way really just cut
straight to the bone well there's a
couple of problems there we thought
about one problem was that it's not
popular at all
it's not popular
at all and then the bigger problem was
is you're already in a recession and
that
you're already in a recession and this
could make the recession more severe
recession
more
severe
and frankly it was not popular it's
never popular but it became
as we move now then in 2012 it's even
less popular because greece has already
gone through a couple of rounds of this
austerity this is not a new problem
they've been bailed out in small ways
and i'll talk more about what a bailout
is but as part of that package the
people who've been bailing them out says
look if we're going to give you
something if we're going to use some of
our own taxpayer money to help you out
you got to cut your spending but what's
happened every round of austerity so far
is that that helped slow the economy
even further that the recession kept
deepening and deepening and it's kind of
common sense that it would if the
government stops spending in a big way
it slows down an already slow economy
now the other thing that you might be
saying well so you know why doesn't why
doesn't greece just stop paying its debt
why doesn't it just default on its debt
so why doesn't it
why doesn't it just default say hey
we're a country i'm sorry investors that
you had to take a loss here but we're
just not paying anymore well the problem
is is it has a situation where it's
spending more than it's bringing in and
its obligations are all in in the euro
it does not have its own currency and so
if they were to default on their debt
the the obviously the people who lent
the money will be very upset and they'll
there's no way that they're going to
lend more money to greece and if they
don't lend more money to greece then
greece
if they don't lend more euros to greece
greece is not going to be able to
continue spending euros the way it has
it's promising all of their that you
know the pension uh retirees the
unemployed insurance it's paying all of
those obligations in euros and if they
default they're not going to be able to
borrow more euros to do those
obligations
and once again it'll kind of be a a very
fast and violent austerity because there
wouldn't even be the money to fund that
and you would have this very
kind of drastic almost shutdown of the
government so this right over here is
not a good option now to start exploring
the third option and this is kind of the
option that it seems likely that greece
might have to go in let's think about
what greece could have done if it had
monetary independence if it had its own
currency so just remember this is
completely this is completely
hypothetical greece did have its own
currency the drachma before it joined
the euro but let's think about what it
could have done in this situation had it
actually if it actually did have its own
currency and it's not cut and dry here
because greece was actually able to and
historically borrowed very cheap rates
because it was part of this eurozone but
let's just think about it if it was in
this situation what it what it could
have done if it had its own central bank
so this is some of the stats from our
last from our last video and if it had
its own central bank and let me make
this very clear this is all hypothetical
greece does not have its own high
central bank right now all of the euro
zone countries the euro is printed by
the european central bank it's not by
any one country but let's say
hypothetically let's say that greece
does have a central bank so greek
greek central
central bank that prints its own let's
call it the new drachma and so that
greek central bank in this type of a
situation could just start printing
drachma
it could just start printing drachma and
essentially use that drachma to buy
government bonds
so it could buy government bonds so it's
essentially printing that money and when
it buys government bonds it's lending it
to the government
it lends to the government so this is
and so the government could spend on
entitlements government could spend
on all of its various obligations
now that might seem very convenient you
know essentially one part of the
government or something pseudo
associated with the government prints
money essentially lends it to the
government funds its obligation but the
immediate thing you might say well hey
if you just print currency like this
willy-nilly
won't this lead
won't this right over here lead to
inflation
inflation and the simple answer is it
probably will but that actually might be
the solution if you're in a conundrum
like what greece is in first of all
inflation might not be so bad it's right
now the country is in a deep recession
so there's all this extra capacity so
you might even have a little bit of a
price cushion and just in general the
inflation rates the inflation rates
aren't ultra-dramatic they're not super
low but they're not super high either so
there might be some
you might not have to worry about kind
of a hyperinflationary situation but on
top of that the government probably
wants a respectable amount of inflation
it might not want 100 percent a thousand
percent inflation but it might like ten
twenty or thirty percent year inflation
and to think about that think about the
idea in this hypothetical grease all of
its obligations would not be in euro its
obligations would be in the drachma
and so you can imagine a world so let's
think of a hypothetical grease and i'm
going to use hypothetical numbers just
to make things
more simple to understand or to do in
our heads let's take this hypothetical
greece it could be greece rarely any
country and let's say it has a gdp it
has
it has a
gdp
of
100 actually i don't know this let's
call it 100
let's call it 100 of its currency it's a
hundred drachma is its gdp and let's say
it has entitlement obligations
and title
entitlement
obligations and this is obligations this
is all on an annual basis of let's say
10 billion of its currency of its
drachma this isn't the situation of
greece all of its obligations are in
euros
but let's just think about the situation
and let's say and let's say that on top
of that it has debt obligations so the
total debt the total value of debt
let's say that it was i don't know let's
say that it was another 150
billion of its currency if you were to
inflate let's say you inflate over a
couple of years so inflation occurs
and let's say it you have a hundred
percent inflation over a few years and
but in real terms your gdp doesn't
change this is really just more of a
thought experiment so then in real terms
if you have 100 inflation but you're
producing the same amount the nominal
value of your gdp will now be will now
be 200 billion it's the same amount of
goods and services but everything now
costs twice as much so you would value
it at 200 billion if you were inflation
adjusted it would still be at 100
billion the good thing and it's very
seldom that you use inflation in a good
context but what would be good about
greece in this situation is that these
entitlement obligations they would still
be they would still be 10 billion you're
still going to say i'm still going to
pay you 10 billion even though that 10
billion is going to buy people half as
much that is much easier to do
politically than telling people
overnight
that i'm going to reduce your pension by
half that's political suicide but to
inflate away the obligations nominally
it looks like you're paying the same
thing but it's just buying less it's a
little bit more viable to do and the
same thing is true of your debt
obligations your debt obligations won't
adjust to inflation and so you would
still owe 150 billion but as a
percentage of gdp you have now half ha
you've halved how big that debt is
you've halved how big the entitlement
obligations are so it has actually a
viable solution and in this hypothetical
situation it's probably the best
solution for government to essentially
inflate
inflate away
its obligations so i'll leave you with
that something for you to think about
and then we could think about what could
greece actually do in this direction but
more important let's think about and you
could start a thing but why is the whole
world so scared all of this is greece
it's a relatively small country why is
why is the whole eurozone so scared why
are people thinking about
bailing out greece in some way to
prevent all of this craziness from
happening and what are the repercussions
in the larger global
market but i'll leave you there and
leave you to think about all this stuff